avec le hashtag rtcs h rendez-vous aussi
sur notre site internet à l'adresse rt
france point tv pour voir ou revoir nos
précédentes émissions
en attendant la semaine prochaine en
skate avec vous pour l'évier et bien
écoutez j'ai aimé comme souhaité qu'on
fasse en effet 0 de croissance pour que
monsieur bruno le maire soient licenciés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la une la propagation des variants du
colis de 19 après la moselle le nord de
la france est touchée
la ville de dunkerque précisément mais
le gouvernement maintient son cas pas
question de reconfirmer localement de
fermer des écoles malgré la pression des
élus il est toujours sur un renforcement
des tests et de la vaccination
[Musique]
le procès en destitution de donald trump
au sénat américain et ce nouveau coup de
théâtre sénateurs républicains et
démocrates ont passé un accord pour
éviter les témoins c'est arrivé après la
décision de convoquer la barre une élue
républicaine
on attend un verdict peut-être dans la
journée l'ex président américain est
accusé d'incitation à l'insurrection
après l'assaut du capitole en janvier
l'algérie demande des comptes à son
ancien colonisateur la france en cause
deux premiers essais nucléaires français
dans le sahara algérien il ya 61 ans
la triste anniversaire
duy l'armée algérienne réclame
décontamination des sites et des
indemnisations les détails c'est à
suivre dans cette édition
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les autorités
gardent le même cap malgré une
accélération de la circulation du
variant angles est pas question de
reconstituer le calme en ou de fermer
les écoles dernières régions touchées le
nord à la ville de dunkerque
les élus de la ville ont demandé
vendredi aux autorités de fermer les
établissements scolaires une semaine
avant les vacances
aujourd'hui la préfecture du nord a
seulement annoncé un renforcement des
mesures contre le coc u19 cela concerne
les tests et la vaccination en une
semaine le taux d'incidence est passé de
384 à 515 cas pour 100000 habitants une
situation similaire à la moselle où le
préfet refuse de fermer les écoles
il s'est exprimé aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de fermeture généralisée des écoles
ni de confinement locales contrairement
à ce que réclamaient certains élus
locaux
ces mesures sont adaptées à la situation
actuelle si dans les prochaines semaines
la situation évolue elle pourrait
évoluer
l'assemblée nationale a approuvé
aujourd'hui un élargissement des motifs
de fermeture des lieux de culte c'était
l'une des dernières dispositions du
projet de loi contre le séparatisme dont
l'examen est maintenant terminée au sein
de l'hémicycle
le vote solennel du texte est prévu
mardi avant de passer au sénat un texte
rebaptisé lois confortant le respect des
principes de la république est dans le
collimateur les mosquées accueillant je
cite des prêcheurs de haine
et puis on reparle de la ville de
trappes dans les yvelines le maire a
allié arabe est sous le coup de menaces
pour avoir critiqué didier lemaire le
professeur de philosophie se dit-on
danger depuis plusieurs semaines à la
suite de son soutien à ses mails pâtit
assassiné en octobre dernier à lire à b
et soutenu par benoît hamon et son parti
génération point s qui dénonce un
déferlement de haine et de menaces de
mort à son encontre
et puis sachez également dans
l'actualité qu'une centaine de sans abri
principalement des migrants soutenu par
des associations occupait cet après midi
l'hôpital de l'hôtel dieu il réclama d
hébergement décent en cette période de
vague de froid et appelle le
gouvernement en faire davantage
hé les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues brièvement mais non pas
disperser la foule
écoutez ce manifestant le gouvernement
depuis quelques jours ils ont annoncé le
grand froid et ils ont annoncé
l'ouverture de pas mal de place mais on
a entendu ça fait trois jours qu'on
attend
ils nous disent d'appeler 115 ça marche
pas ils nous disent les maraudes de nuit
ils vont passer dans paris et du coup on
est obligé de les faire remonter sur
paris parce que la préfecture de police
tous les réfugiés en dehors de paris on
réfléchit ensemble pour trouver des
endroits symboliques pour que le
gouvernement nous écoute sinon ça marche
pas si on reste sous les ponts est ce
que vous croyez vraiment qu'ils vont
venir s'intéresser à nous sous les ponts
en dehors de paris en banlieue
non ça marche pas c'est pour ça qu'on
est obligé d'organiser des actions puis
le début de semaine les pouvoirs publics
nous disent que c'est le plan grand
froid qui sont ouverts des places
d'hébergement et nous les collectifs et
associations de terrain ce qu'on
constate sur le terrain c'est qu'en fait
il ya des centaines si ce n'est des
milliers de gens dans paris qui reste
dehors malgré le grand froid et malgré
la pandémie qui dure depuis dix mois et
pendant et que
ici ce lieu c'est un hôpital qui est en
train d'être vidée qui en gros il réunit
fonctionne encore à 10% à peu près ses
capacités et qu'il ya des dizaines de
milliers de mètres carrés libre ici où
les gens pourraient être au chaud ici il
y en à paris mais on a pris ce lieu là
parce qu'il est symbolique il est au
coeur de paris musée anticorps devra
encore attendre le délai d'instruction
du renouvellement de son agrément a de
nouveau été prolongée l'agrément lui
permet de porter plein dans les affaires
politico financières en cas de perte
justement de cet agrément plusieurs
dossiers judiciaires très médiatique
dans l'association est à l'origine
risque de finir à la trappe
[Musique]
beaucoup
vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
en
[Musique]
oh
tu es et rittal télé vice président de
l'association anticor et magistrats
selon lui le rapport de cette
instruction est une décision politique
le grand paradoxe c'est que le
renouvellement de l'agrément c'est une
décision qui appartient au gouvernement
alors que un certain nombre de membres
du gouvernement ou de proches du pouvoir
sont concernés par nos actions donc jean
castex va de vraiment devoir faire
preuve d'une loyauté républicaine pour
renouveler cet agrément je pense qu'il y
à des tensions qu'il ya des appels pour
ne pas qu'on ne pas le renouveler
et encore une fois je suis sûr ben je
pense que de diverses personnes qui sont
dérangés par nos actions ou qui
pourraient être dérangé par nos actions
car nous avons effectivement un certain
nombre de proches du pouvoir mais nous
avons aussi sur l'ensemble du territoire
nationale à portefeuille d'actions il ya
des lanceurs dallaire qui nous concerne
qui qui ne concerne qu ils signalent des
fins et tout ceci jeunes un peu en
italie mario draghi a prêté serment
comme premier ministre il a été choisi
par le président sergio matar est là
elle succède à giuseppe compter l'ex
président de la banque centrale
européenne a pour mission de sortir le
pays de la crise politique et sanitaire
hier mario draghi a présenté les
ministres qui composent son gouvernement
par mail ou gmail au ministre des
affaires étrangères et chef du mouvement
5 étoiles ou encore daniel francke au
ministre de l'économie écouter fabien
gibeau enseignant à l'université de
turin les objectifs principalement il
est déjà presque réussi c'est à dire de
redonner une certaine confiance pour
l'économie italienne au niveau européen
bien sûr mario draghi est une personne
qui a beaucoup travaillé en europe et
pour le vent donc il a déjà apporté
cette réputation qui permet de
stabiliser le niveau économique italien
c'était le premier objectif ensuite il
va falloir se mettre au travail il ya
une certaine curiosité
des observateurs politiques en italie
parce que comment mario draghi va
réussir à travailler avec d'un nombre de
ministres 10 arrêts surtout deux bords
politiques très différents il va falloir
faire travailler toutes ces personnes
ensemble et ça risque d'être un petit
peu compliqué pour cette équipe qui l'a
dessinée d'une équipe plutôt
d'économistes en général même les
personnes qu'il a choisi dans les
parties les plus populistes
par exemple il a choisi monsieur
giorgetti comme ministre donc de la
relance économique qui est donc de la
ligue mais qui est la partie la plus
modérée de la vie dure mais moins de
curiosité pour savoir comment il va
réussir à faire travailler toutes ces
personnes ensemble
j'en parlais avec les éternels hier et
c'était la vraie question comment faire
travailler des personnes de bord très
différents qui se sont parfois opposé
pendant des années vous avez le parti
démocrate avec les personnes qui ont été
opposés pendant 20 ans à silvio
berlusconi et qui aujourd'hui n'ont
travaillé avec le parti ce double
austruy ça va être très difficile de
trouver des symbioses à l'intérieur du
gouvernement
mais je pense que beaucoup sont
confiants par rapport à l'autorité de
mario draghi sa capacité justement de
faire ce travail et de consort des
personnes nouveau rebondissement dans le
procès en destitution de donald trump
les démocrates ont voulu appeler à un
témoin à la barre l'élue républicaine
qui a fait des révélations sur la
latitude de donald trump a accusé donc
de d'incitation à l'insurrection après
l'assaut du capitole en janvier
finalement le sénat a fait machine
arrière
il a simplement ajouté le témoignage
public de cet élu au dossier faut savoir
que les sénateurs républicains les
démocrates ont passé un accord pour
éviter justement les témoins d'un retour
donc à la case départ en quelque sorte
en tout cas le verdict on l'attend
possiblement aujourd'hui on va écouter
l'analyse de didier groupon spécialiste
des états unis auteur de l'ouvragé
être américain aujourd'hui les enjeux
d'une élection présidentielle aux
éditions gallimard
c'est un procès qui est plein de
rebondissements comme les élections
était elle-même pleine de
rebondissements lorsqu'elles se sont
déroulées les cessna intérêts de
personne que le que le procès dure trop
longtemps et donc la convocation des
témoins ne le fait que le sénat ait
décidé par 55 voix contre 45 de
convoquer des témoins était une surprise
il est finalement moins étonnant que
qu'un accord ait été trouvé puisque les
démocrates ont intérêt à ce que le conte
le congrès le sénat puisse reprendre ses
activités normales pour mettre en place
la politique de l'administration maiden
et puis les républicains bien entendu
auront intérêt à éviter que ce procès
traîne en longueur parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est qui divise
beaucoup à l'intérieur de leur camp s'il
trump n'est pas condamnée comme ce sera
probablement le cas
ses partisans ont beau jeu de dire voyez
il ya eu un il fit semaine qui a eu un
procès mais c'était une manoeuvre
politique et reims n'était pas coupable
s'il était condamné ce qui est moins
probable et bien semblé être un martyr
de l'establishment et c'est quelque
chose qui à son égard lg célèbre
aujourd'hui un triste anniversaire il ya
61 ans premier essai nucléaire de la
france dans le sahara algérien ces
autres ont suivi jusqu'en 1966 l algérie
demande aujourd'hui réparation encore en
un dossier épineux entre ce pays et son
ancien colonisateur
on voit cela avec david khalifa nous
sommes le 13 février 1960 une bombe au
plutonium plus puissante que celle
d'hiroshima explose à reggane dans le
sahara algérien baptisé gerboise bleue
cette opération est le premier essai
nucléaire de la france et concrétise le
voeu du général de gaulle formulée dès
1945 est de rejoindre le club des
puissances disposant la bombe atomique
avec les états unis et l'urss seize
autres essais auront lieu par la suite
entre 1960 et 1966 sur les sites de
reggane et puis d'in eker pendant quatre
ans et conformément aux accords d'evian
qui acte et l'indépendance de l'algérie
la france a continué à utiliser jusqu'en
1967 les sites du sahara pour ses essais
nucléaires
les conséquences sur les populations
locales et l'environnement sont devenus
un sujet de contentieux entre la france
et l'algérie
celle ci demande à son ancienne
puissance coloniale d'en prendre acte et
d'agir en conséquence
la france doit assumer ses
responsabilités historiques surtout
après que 122 états de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu ont ratifié le 7
juillet 2010 est un nouveau traité sur
l'interdiction des armes nucléaires qui
vient s'ajouter aux traités antérieurs
le principe du pollueur payeur qui a été
d'ailleurs introduit et reconnue
officiellement
c'est la première fois que la communauté
internationale demande aux puissances
nucléaires de rectifier les erreurs du
passé
soixante et un ans plus tard le général
bout fria réclame à la france au nom de
l'algérie de remettre les cartes
de localisation des déchets nucléaires
et de décontaminer les sites toujours
potentiellement nocifs
sans oublier l'indemnisation des
victimes des souvenirs douloureux est
teintée d'émotion qui persistent dans
les mémoires pour les habitants de régal
il était 7 heures du matin nous avons
senti la terre bouger sous nos pieds
c'était l'heure de la prière quand je
suis sorti de chez moi il y avait une
fumée blanche dans le ciel du jamais vu
cette lumière est resté pendant trois
jours les gens qui avaient des bêtes les
ont vus devenir aveugle à cause de cette
lumière
je n'oublierai jamais la frayeur causée
par la bombe aucune étude sérieuse de
montres à ce jour les répercussions
écologiques et sanitaires de ces essais
nucléaires entre 1900 et 1966 mais pour
le professeur mustapha baouchi doom
responsable des maladies cancéreuses et
de l'hôpital elle d'adrar et installé
dans la région depuis 30 ans l existence
de plusieurs pathologies qui ont été
observés pourraient être liés à ces
essais 29 pathologie au total qui serait
susceptible d'avoir comme cause la
radioactivité due à une explosion
atomique des probabilités selon les
termes à du docteur o'shea d'où une
difficulté pour les victimes qui
souhaiteraient porter l affaire devant
les instances internationales certains
algériens parlent même de crime contre
l'humanité
concernant ce que dit macro et les
crimes importante de la france en
algérie nous en tant qu'algérien nous
devons avoir une position unifiée entre
le peuple et le gouvernement contre
macro et la france pour les obliger à
reconnaître les crimes commis en algérie
les très grands crimes les crimes contre
l'humanité sans précédent dans le monde
lundi 8 février le gouvernement algérien
réagi via son porte parole en demandant
à la france une nouvelle fois de
reconnaître ses crimes coloniaux et
pourtant en février 2010 est le candidat
rateront en déplacement en algérie avait
reconnu la demande algérienne
la nécessité d'une repentance une
attitude qui a évolué en endossant le
costume de chef d'état adou la demande
en juillet 2020 d'un rapport à
l'historien benjamin stora sur la
réconciliation mémorielle entre
l'algérie et la france a déposé le 21
janvier dernier emmanuel macron s'est
engagé à prendre des actes symboliques
pour apaiser les mémoires mais a exclu
de présenter les excuses demandées par
alger la réconciliation a donc encore
beaucoup de chemin devant elle au brésil
les autorités indiquent que le variant
identifié sur le territoire pourrait
être trois fois plus contagieux à manaus
une ville particulièrement touché les
habitants se ruent dans les centres de
vaccination au bord de la saturation
wesley avec médias ce qui fit une files
d'attentes interminables pour recevoir
la précieuse injection et une inquiétude
qui grandit autour du variant identifié
en amazonie annoncé trois fois plus
contagieux par le gouvernement une
souche mutante qui pourrait tout de même
être contrôlés par les vaccins d'après
le ministre brésilien de la santé à
manaus le personnel médical restent
néanmoins préoccupés
[Musique]
je suis inquiète de cette situation nous
n'avons jamais rien vécu de tel
nous voyons donc ici à quel point la
vaccination est importante pour prévenir
ce variant j'espère que la population se
fera vacciner car j'ai déjà perdu
beaucoup de personnes des gens qui
travaillent en première ligne comme moi
nous vivons un moment très difficile et
l'arrivée du vaccin n'arrêtera pas les
autres mesures
nous continuerons à utiliser des masques
depuis le 18 janvier le brésil vaccine
sa population avec deux remèdes
approuvée par les autorités
celui développé par la firme britannique
astrazeneca ainsi que corona vac le
sérum mise au point par le laboratoire
chinois sinopharm les habitants de
manaus compte sur une montée en
puissance de la campagne de vaccination
et un renforcement des restrictions pour
endiguer l'épidémie
ce nouveau variant m'inquiète on
s'attend à prendre des précautions avec
l'administration du vaccin et
l'intensification du confinement par des
mesures gouvernementales
d'après l'université johns hopkins le
brésil est le deuxième pays au monde le
plus touché par la pandémie qui en
termes de morts avec plus de 230 7000
décès liés aux copies de 19 quelques
semaines après avoir autorisé
l'utilisation du vaccin spoutnik v la
hongrie a commencé à vacciner sa
population hier il s'agit du premier
pays de l'union européenne à utiliser le
sérum russe
on voit cela avec isabelle karas course
première dose inoculé dans un état
membre de l'union européenne du vaccin
spoutnik v la hongrie a commencé ce
vendredi à vacciner sa population en
utilisant le sérum russe déjà première
états membres de l'ue à approuver
spoutnik vais le mois dernier le pays a
commandé deux millions de doses
livrables sur trois mois assez pour
vacciner un million de personnes soit
10% de la population
aujourd'hui nous commençons à vacciner
avec le vaccin spoutnik v
cela se passe dans des centres de
vaccination prix déterminé dans un
premier temps 2008 son dos seront
disponibles
2 chez une hongrie à contre-courant du
reste de l'europe sur fond de critiques
de budapest à l'égard des lenteurs selon
elle du processus d'approbation des
vaccins par l' agence européenne des
médicaments
le premier ministre viktor orban en
habitué des bras de fer avec bruxelles
avait fustigé ces retards lors de la
validation de scouting fait par son pays
si on est rapide on sauve des vies si on
est lent on perd des vies c'est pour
cela que nous ne pouvons pas attendre
bruxelles la fourniture de vaccins par
bruxelles est lente mais nous ne sommes
pas ici pour critiquer ce n'est pas
encore le moment pour cela nous voulons
au contraire apprendre les uns des
autres et voir comment faire pour
accélérer l'obtention de vaccins
bruxelles qui n'a toujours pas fait
homologuer le vaccin russe par son
agence du médicament
l'union européenne s'est montré jusqu'à
présent méfiante reprochant à la russie
un manque de transparence et le
développement du vaccin dans la
précipitation
mais le 2 février dernier la
prestigieuse revue médicale the lancet
tu a confirmé par la publication d'une
étude l'efficacité à 91,6 % de scouts
nick v le classant parmi les vaccins les
plus performants avec ceux des
laboratoires occidentaux pfizer biotech
et moderne
les conclusions des notes de l'étude
sont sans appel le développement du
vaccin spoutnik v a été critiqué pour sa
précipitation
le fait que des étapes et été brûlés et
l'absence de transparence mais les
résultats rapportés ici sont claires et
le principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontrée la
prestigieuse revue médicale a aussi
souligné certaines performances sans
pareil de spoutnik v relativement peu
coûteux plus facile à conserver à
transporter il rencontre aussi une bonne
tolérance avec des effets indésirables
très limité et même une protection
évalué à 73 pour cent quinze jours après
la première dose
des échanges sont toujours en cours
entre la russie et l'agencé européenne
des médicaments en vue de la validation
du vaccin
berlin paris et madrid se disent d'ores
et déjà prêt à recourir à ce putsch nick
v s'il reçoit le feu vert de l'instance
européenne
la russie pourrait alors fournir 100
millions de doses à l'union européenne
dès le deuxième trimestre et pour un
accès équitable au vaccin c'est une mise
en garde et un appel d'experts
aujourd'hui dans une lettre ouverte
publiée dans the lancet est en ligne de
mire les pays riches et les oubliés de
cette crise mondiale illustration avec
le mozambique
noémie wira lancé par l' oms en avril
2020 le mécanisme kovacs achète et livre
des vaccins aux pays les plus pauvres
notamment en afrique
problème cette initiative peine à
atteindre son objectif sur le milliard
300 millions de doses confirmé pour 2021
seulement 39 millions de doses ont été
administrées jusqu'à présent au
mozambique les organisations caritatives
ne voit pas le bout du tunnel
selon elle il faudra compter plusieurs
années avant que la vaccination contre
le coc vie 19,7 effectifs dans le pays
au moins trois à cinq ans avant le
déploiement trois à cinq ans c'est long
vous pouvez avoir des gens qui vivent à
50 km de la ville de maputo
mais cela fait 50 ans qu'ils ne viennent
jamais à maputo
ils vivent à côté mais ils ne viendront
jamais juste pour se faire vacciner
mais après l'apparition du variant sud
africain le mozambique se retrouve
confronté à l'urgence
face à l'envolée des nouveaux cas
d'infection et à l'augmentation du taux
d'admission les hôpitaux ont dû mettre
en place des tentes de fortune pour
disposer de 140 lits supplémentaires
ce variant circulent probablement dans
toute l'afrique subsaharienne
il ne faut pas que maintenant face à ce
problème le système sanitaire s'effondre
invariants qui inquiète également la
population c'est dangereux on n'a pas de
temps à perdre
on sent petit à petit que l'on commence
à manquer d'air
dans le pays les mesures préventives se
sont révélés inefficaces car une grande
partie de la population ne peut pas se
permettre de rester à la maison sans
travailler si nous restons à la maison
nous n'avons pas à manger vous comprenez
et nous allons mourir
nous ne mourrons pas dû qu'au vide nous
mourons de faim
nous avons plus peur de la fin que du
coc vide une situation critique
de son côté l'union africaine a commandé
270 millions de doses de vaccins pour
les pays du continent
en plus de celles prévues par le
dispositif kovacs plus de deux siècles
après leur mort de militaires russes et
français inhumer ensemble avec les
honneurs c'était aujourd'hui en russie
126 soldat du tsar et grognards
napoléoniens tous tombés lors de la
retraite de russie en 1812
leurs cadavres ont été découverts dans
une fosse commune en 2019
présent à la cérémonie des descendants
de généraux et ont participé à la
bataille dans les deux camps l'occasion
de réaffirmer aussi les liens entre
paris et moscou à un moment c'est vrai
où on assiste à un regain de tension
entre la russie et l'europe on regarde
maintenant le reste de l'actualité
internationale
en bref et en images manifestation est
la nuit dernière de plusieurs milliers
de vénézuéliens à caracas
un rassemblement en soutien au président
les colas maduro ce dernier a prononcé
un discours au palais de miraflores
il est revenu sur la crise humanitaire
que traverse le pays
marasme je cite énorme selon ses propres
mots il pointe du doigt les sanctions
économiques contre le venezuela
également
manifestations également hier soir en
haïti avec des heurts entre forces de
l'ordre et militants anti
gouvernementaux à port-au-prince la
capitale
les contestataires réclament le départ
du président et si un jeu est née louise
alors que l'opposition a à nommer un
dirigeant censé assurer la transition
politique
d'autres scènes de violences à santiago
au chili la nuit dernière
un événement qui interviennent à la
suite de la mort d'un jongleur de rue
tués par les forces de l'ordre lors d'un
contrôle d'identité est le pays est
secoué par une forte contestation
sociale depuis plus d'un an notamment
pour exiger la démission du président
conservateur sebastian pinera et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver dans 30
minutes pour une nouvelle édition rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
avec le climat ou encore la crise
sanitaire la crise économique est l'un
des principaux défis qui attendent joe
biden nous avons plus de 20 millions de
personnes qui perçoivent des indemnités
de chômage maintenant le plan de
monsieur byden ne remet pas